it's roz custom to leave behind the
instrument of death as a memorial to
honor the fallen the brains
what happens next
hey youtubers what's up this video is
going to be a breakdown of the arrow
footage but there's also been a bunch of
news about the flash and arrow that they
just released at a big tcas panel
including new spin-off shows what's
going to be happening you know they
confirmed renewals arrow season 4 in the
flash season 2 so I'll explain all that
after the arrow footage so starting off
this is just like the flash trailer I
posted yesterday it only covers episode
10 but it sets up the next mini story
arc Oliver's gone so evil Rises in the
glades primarily in the form of vidiians
here who's playing brick from the comics
he's gonna be a lot of fun he's always
fun when he plays like these ridiculous
comic book characters on the show he's
gonna be more of like an enterprising
gang leader like vertigo at the
beginning of the season I know
everyone's wondering where he went yeah
he'll be back vertigo is coming back to
the show he's going to be part of
laurels Black Canary arc I don't know
how that's gonna play out but Vinnie
Jones here is going to be the first big
villain that the new team arrow or the
slightly modified team arrow is gonna
have to defeat team arrow is changing a
little they lost Oliver but they're
gaining Laurel I think that Brandon
Ralph will help out and I think you know
indirectly Merlyn is going to help them
he's not gonna you know go fight with
him he's not gonna pal around with him
but he's training Thea and I think that
Thea is going to help out too on on her
own like off on the side Vinnie Jones is
gonna be like the next real villain so
when you're thinking of bad guys on the
show think more about Vinnie Jones and
vertigo we do see Oliver in the trailer
they extended the scene you know like of
him on the mountaintop this person
carrying the body to the door I had a
theory that I think I mentioned my
episode 9 video that Merlyn was going to
be the one carrying him away we actually
see Merlyn in this scene here in the
arrow cave placing the sword on the
table you know but giant asterisk if
Merlyn comes back to Starling with the
sword that means that someone else has
to take care of Oliver back in this
place I think that's probably Masayo I
wouldn't be surprised if Nyssa helps out
somehow to that all play out eventually
over the course of the season like
they'll they'll answer that question
definitively I think we really all just
want to know what's behind that door I
did post a theory video a little while
ago about Merlyn being one of the new
potential heroes of the back half of the
season I don't think he's going to be a
white knight type of hero but I think
that by saving Oliver like rescuing him
off this mountaintop qualifies I think a
lot of people were confused by what I
meant when I said that Merlin's going to
be one of the new heroes
I did say regardless I think he's going
to be evil by the end of the season
again like the traditional Merlin that
you're used to but in the short term
he's going to be a lot more helpful than
he is hurtful and when I say that he's
still going to be Merlin
but if he's helping train Thea and Thea
helps take down criminals then by
default you could consider him a good
person like the real twist though is is
what is he going to do at the end of the
season to switch back it's like you
shake up all the characters during the
season and then you have to reset them
by the end so like you know Oliver for
instance right now we think he's dead
they have to restore him by the end of
the season Merlyn on the other hand
acting unusually helpful they also have
to reset him by the end of the season
so that he is back at odds with Oliver
so that they're both back at each
other's throats
even though Rachele goal is the biggest
humanoid villain in the DC Universe I
think that Merlyn is always going to be
Oliver's biggest villain marc guggenheim
said something really interesting
recently where he talked about the way
arrow treats its comic book characters
he said there's a lot of people from the
comics that he thinks were done poorly
that arrow does better versions of and I
think Merlin's an example that like a
character who's really interesting in
the comics who wasn't executed in the
best possible way so when it came time
for arrow to do his character they tried
to do it the way they thought it should
be done I think what they're doing with
his character is amazing
Captain Jack and Merlyn ride-or-die
although technically they can't die
moving on to next more obvious hero
Ray Palmer so he's going to be testing
out his atom suit in the next couple of
episodes
I don't think we'll actually see like
the full-on real dil atom suit like
working till much later in the season
but we will see pieces of it before then
he's going to be one of the new white
knight heroes the real big news though
at the TCAs was that they are working on
an atom spin-off show I think you know
some people won't be surprised by that
The CW is developing a couple new
spin-off shows in the atom is just going
to be like one of the first ones they
didn't say when it's going to air they
just said that they're working on it so
it could be the end of this year it
could be next year they'll probably have
some more news about that at Comic Con
this summer
like usually Comic Con is when they make
big reveals like that I'm always
interested by the way things behind the
scenes change that the way their plans
change over time initially he was
supposed to be the Blue Beetle character
they couldn't do that so they made him
the atom originally they wanted him to
go on the flash in season 2 just because
the Ray Palmer character naturally fits
in with
STAR Labs crowd because of his tech
background cut to now they're even
changing it in a bigger way turning it
into its own show so if you're confused
as to like why all these sudden new
shows are just like coming all over the
place there's this big thing going on at
the CW behind the scenes it has to do
with the way that they program their
channel so the CW is dependent upon
affiliates to carry its programming like
channels all over the United States like
that's where it gets its ratings from
that it's where it gets its audience
there was some financial news a little
while ago that the deal the CW has with
its affiliates like the contract it has
is up for renewal and the affiliates
aren't super happy with the programming
the CW has right now or they weren't
happy before arrow and the flash came
along it just they felt that the CW was
too niche and serving too much of a
female audience and just wasn't broad
enough like they needed something
broader which means airing more shows
that males ages 18 to 34 watch that
sounds kind of technical but the
takeaway is more male driven superhero
shows which is why you're hearing about
an atom spin-off show so just in general
in the next couple of years you'll see
like a ton more superhero shows from the
CW which is why I think that they did
not pick up the Supergirl show why that
went to CBS because it's a female-driven
superhero show and they want more male
driven superhero shows that's just
speculation about them passing on
Supergirl so the next big news that they
announced were crossovers that's totally
going to be a yearly thing it's totally
going to happen before the midseason
finale just like it did this year the
extra little bit though is the Supergirl
news so Supergirl will crossover with
the other shows there's a rumor that is
actually inside Greg Berlanti s contract
with CBS which i think is kind of funny
like there's something that says you
have to let me allow this Supergirl show
to crossover with these other networks
shows I think that's better for everyone
at the end of the day though it just
makes things easier for the producers
behind the scenes to do things that they
want to do moving along Tom Cavanagh
made a big flash revelation so I'll just
say general spoiler warning for Harrison
wells character it's not really
technically spoilery but I'm just gonna
say just in case I'll put this spoiler
tag up for a second here we go okay so
Tom Cavanagh said I am the reverse-flash
what he did not say is which version of
the reverse-flash he is they're going to
answer that question before the end of
the season but here's what I think is
going on and I think I said this in my
reverse-flash video or my episode 9
video
Harrison wells is both of these people
here in this bubble there's two people
two distinct people one of them is just
a future version of Harrison wells and
they're working together otherwise how
would he have gotten this device the
showrunner andrew kriesberg
also confirmed eddie thawne totally
connected to the reverse-flash lineage
to the lore from the comics he didn't
say how but also here's what I think is
going on with that I think Eddie Thawne
is the originator of the reverse-flash
lineage and Harrison wells character is
his descendant Harrison wells is like
from the far future any thoughts from
present-day
so I think at some point this season we
will see Eddie Thawne become the
reverse-flash I think that's going to be
like the big reveal it's really clear
Harrison wells wants Barry Allen to
achieve his potential as the flash the
question is why you know when you look
at these Gideon scenes you can see he's
clearly trying to achieve some specific
future outcome so we really need to
think about what Harrison wells wants to
happen in the future and for those that
are asking I think some of you guys
picked up on this already Morena
Baccarin is actually the voice of Gideon
remember she just came on Gotham as a
comic book character most people
remember her from Firefly though there's
also a new show called vixen that's
debuting it's a new character it's going
to be animated it'll be inside the
arrowverse Oliver Queen and Barry Allen
will totally show up on it like they'll
totally have cameos and I would expect
that Grant Gustin and Stephen Amell will
do their voices on the show but it'll be
animated Marc Guggenheim the showrunner
on arrows gonna oversee it it'll be part
of the CWC programming so it'll be a
digital show it won't be on air it won't
be on TV
she'll have real-deal powers though
she'll have superpowers it'll be kind of
like Animal Man she'll find a totem
that'll give her the power to take
animals abilities one animal at a time
so here's my big question for you guys
what from all this news are you most
excited about you know flash season 2
arrow season 4 new spin-off shows I feel
like I'm going to have to hire a couple
assistants to help me handle all the new
videos for these new comic book shows
that I'm gonna have to be doing this
fall I'm actually not joking about that
part at a certain point I will I will
need a lot of help so big stuff
happening tomorrow so in addition to a
new Gotham episode there's going to be a
new Avengers age of Ultron trailer I'll
be posting that Monday night so be sure
to subscribe to get it
I am expecting there to be new footage
it's a little early but what I'm really
hoping is is that we get to see footage
of the vision
so while you guys wait for that you can
click here for my flash trailer video
that I posted yesterday and you can
click here to learn about what's
happening on the next couple of episodes
of arrow thank you so much watching so
let's all high-five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you